rotoscoping is an animation technique
used to trace over motion picture film
frame by frame to reproduce lifelike
movement the technology of brochure
scoping was invented 100 years ago by
pioneer animator Max Fleischer in this
early example filmed footage of Cab
Calloway was used to recreate the
animated dance moves of Minnie the
moocher since then the term has
broadened beyond hand-drawn animation to
digital visual effects but at its heart
the principle is the same to trace and
cut out objects or characters for
isolating and compositing then digital
painting is applied to remove unwanted
bits like wires rigs or even equipment
and the work of roto and paint artists
is not only time consuming but is
applied across a majority of shots in a
film even a simple background
replacement shot is not so simple and
the audience might not realize that the
scene could require dozens of cutouts
with elaborate movement wouldn't it be
great if there was one easy to use
software that can do both roto and
digital painting well I'm here to tell
you there is one you're welcome
this is silhouette
Paul Thomas Miller and Marco Paolini the
Academy presents you both a technical
achievement award for silhouettes but
you have to walk up here to get it come
on come on
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a great video package we almost
look like a real company but seriously
it's it's really an honor to be up here
tonight thanks to the Academy the
members of our investigative committee
and - Adam Bradley and Eddie Surya of
what a digital who as part of the awards
process showed the most complex and
articulated rotoscoping we've ever seen
we also like to thank our customers for
sticking with us all these years we
wouldn't be here without you
but Paul and I are receiving the award
tonight but creating software is a team
effort
Peter Moyer and Perry kavala let's make
up the rest of our team and sharing this
success
we're all happy to know that our efforts
have made a contribution to the art and
science of filmmaking and last but not
least special thanks go out to our wives
and children for all their support thank
you I just have to thank my parents who
when I was eight year old eight years
old they gave me a computer they they
still have no idea what I do have to
take my my wife Erin who was here at I
used my my biggest fan and maybe my only
fan but it's important so thank you and
also to the Academy thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]